dans un instant notre grand entretien
avec audrey azoulay lancé le ministre de
la culture est aujourd'hui directrice
générale de l'unesco
avec elle on va tenter de prendre un
petit peu de hauteur sur cette pandémie
et sur son impact au niveau mondial
éducation culture égalité femmes hommes
comment se situe la france comment
redresser la barre on va commencer par
s'intéresser aux effets très négatifs de
la pandémie pour les femmes
c'est comme si en un an trente ans
d'avancé avaient été effacés voyez ce
reportage édifiant de soleil oissel
alors de quoi se compose un terminal et
dont on peut faire tous les matins c'est
le même rituel
nadia a sur les devoirs à la maison pour
ses quatre enfants
mais sa journée de travail ne se limite
pas qu'à cette tâche éducative
ce qui est difficile c'est de total y
est enfin voila c'est surtout ça qui est
difficile c'est tout c'est composer avec
tout ça le quotidien sai on s'arrête
jamais du moins de mon salaire jusqu'au
soir on s'est réduit depuis septembre
dernier
nadia a perdu son emploi suite à des
arrêts pour garde d'enfants son ancien
employeur lui a imposé une rupture
conventionnelle
je voyais pas comment j'aurais pu
travailler si avec quatre enfants à la
maison
à plein temps je jeu c'est impossible de
dégager du temps pour faire ça c'était
parce que j'ai choisi de prendre du
recul pour ma famille et parce qu'il ya
eu toute cette période de kobe tu qu'on
m'a dit balla en fait tes choix ne me
correspond pas merci au revoir
pour autant mme nadia n'est pas la seule
à s'occuper des enfants avec son mari
ils sont parvenus à une bonne
organisation mais pas d'arrêts de
travail envisageable pour etienne qui
est le dirigeant de sa propre entreprise
là en ayant ma boîte j'étais très libre
mais très libre mais pour autant enfin
c'est toujours pareil corde à sa boîte
on pense qu'on est très libre mais en
fait pour nous entraîner un peu sa boîte
du coup et heureusement que nadia était
dans une structure avec un
fonctionnement adapté et moi j'ai pu
travailler sinon ça aurait été compliqué
même si le couple a trouvé un équilibre
leur situation n'est pas anodine car
pendant le premier confinement une femme
un emploi sur trois s'est retrouvé à
l'arrêt le rapport de la fondation des
femmes publié le 28 mars est sans appel
la crise sanitaire a eu un impact
important sur l'emploi des femmes
c'est deux fois plus souvent les femmes
qui se sont arrêtées de travailler parce
que c'est lié au rôle traditionnel j'ai
envie de dire même patriarcaux qui
considère que c'est aux femmes de
s'occuper des enfants du foyer aux
hommes d'aller travailler je caricature
mais ça ça laisse des traces
et puis aussi est quelque chose de très
pragmatique c'est que dans trois couples
sur quatre l'homme gagne plus mais les
inégalités femmes hommes ont aussi été
exacerbées au niveau de la répartition
des tâches domestiques
c'est tout l'objet de l'avis rendu par
le cee près de trois quarts des femmes
estime en faire plus que leur conjoint
dans le foyer
les inégalités de répartition des tâches
étaient déjà là en valeur avant la crise
néanmoins il y avait un léger progrès
qui avaient été constatés et là
malheureusement avec la crise en a
retrouvé des chiffres avec 72 % des
tâches ménagères assumées par les femmes
dans les foyers bien sûr les hommes
souffrent mais quand même la différence
et 19% des hommes on déclarait avoir ce
sentiment d'épuisement de charges menthe
elle alors que pour les femmes c'est 25%
l'avis du cse a été présenté devant les
sénateurs ce jeudi matin
parmi les préconisations allouer une
part plus importante du plan de relance
aux secteurs qui emploient
majoritairement les femmes
l'onu estime pour sa part que la crise
sanitaire a fait perdre 30 années
d'avancé sur l'égalité femmes-hommes
bonsoir audrey azoulay
bonsoir vous êtes directrice générale de
l'unesco vous avez été ministre de la
culture entre 2016 et 2017
d'abord votre réaction à ce reportage
est édifiant de solenn boissel je le
disais l'onu estime que la crise
sanitaire a fait perdre 30 années
d'avancé sur l'égalité femmes hommes
elles sont les premières à avoir perdu
leur emploi ils ont dû s'occuper des
enfants du foyer etc
votre réaction à ce constat qu assez
terrible quand même oui malheureusement
c'est un constat tout à fait exact cette
crise a été la crise de la régression
pour toutes les avancées qui avait eu
pour les femmes en général dans les
domaines de l'unesco dans l'éducation la
culture les sciences la formation on le
voit c'est vrai par exemple les femmes
scientifiques je peux a envoyé récemment
les femmes scientifiques ont publié
beaucoup moins de recherche ces temps ci
parce qu'elle est robuste de charge de
famille et sert donc on voit que dès
qu'il ya une fragilité en fait cette
crise a pesé sur toutes les fragilités
et là où il y avait une faille
elles se sont accrues elles se sont
élargies et oui c'est une crise qui a
surtout agi comme un révélateur un
amplificateur de situations d'inégalité
qui en fait sont déjà installées elles
ont les emplois les plus fragiles les
moins payés par exemple les femmes et ça
s'est encore aggravée voilà et c'est
vraiment et c'est vrai dans tous les
domaines c'est à dire c'est vrai aussi
par exemple les inégalités entre les
pays
les inégalités au sein des sociétés et
l'inégalité par contre qu'il a plus
largement partagée c'est celle entre les
hommes et les femmes et comment pour
vous expliquer cette situation
d'inégalité initial qui vous l'avez dit
reste très présente de très nombreux
pays quelle que soit la culture est ce
que on a une société qui reste
patriarcal dans son ensemble parce que
c'est la maternité par exemple qui
fragilise les andros et elles
fragilisent les femmes aux yeux des
employeurs dans un pays comme le nôtre
où dans de très nombreux pays
c'est vrai qu'il ya des âges différents
dans les fragilités et le moment pour
les jeunes femmes de la maternité
c'est un moment de fragilité parce que
c'est là où peuvent se décider des
carrières professionnelles et donc il
faut avoir des politiques très très
ciblée sur ces âges là mais moi ce que
je vois beaucoup et ce qui fait partie
pleinement de ce que fait l'unesco c'est
les inégalités qui se joue à la racine
dans l'éducation
ça peut être l'accès à l'éducation mais
c'est aussi le choix d orientation le
choix des carrières oui eh bien
justement on l'a dit c'est une situation
sur l'inégalité homme femme qui a été
lié dans de nombreux pays et par exemple
en france on a vu dans le reportage au
fait que les mères sont nombreuses à
s'être arrêté pour s'occuper des enfants
en l'absence d'école écoutez dominique
joseph qui s'est exprimé ce matin lors
d'une table ronde au sénat sur ce sujet
l'incitation des femmes c'est pas voulu
c'est subie à quitter le monde du
abriter le mot le marché du travail
l'école à la maison a eu un effet
vraiment épiler l'organisation pour les
vacances scolaires pour les vacances et
tout autour de la garde des enfants
c'est que l on était majoritaire et ça
ce sont les chiffres de l'assurance
maladie obligatoire à recourir aux
congés enfants malades ou qui aussi en
enfin en tt en temps en réduction de
l'activité ou en activité partielle
alors on a parlé des femmes on a parlé
des mères mais ce que les filles aussi
ont pâti de cette pandémie et notamment
en terme de scolarisation
on a vécu quelque chose de fou sur
l'école au plus fort de la pandémie à un
an
on s'est retrouvé presque du jour au
lendemain avec 90% des enfants c'est 1,6
milliard d'enfants hors de l'école avec
des écoles fermées
donc on mesure tous quelle école en
réalité parce que l'école c'est bien sûr
le lieu où on apprend et je vais y
revenir pour les filles mais c'est aussi
le lieu où on est nous
il le lieu où on est protégé oui c'est
le lieu qui permet aux maires de
travailler c'est le en fait c'est un
avis l'augmentation dès violences
intrafamiliales on a vu les problèmes de
nutrition que pouvait provoquer et dans
une alliance de cantines d'angers dans
tous les pays et alors et encore plus
dans effectivement dans les pays les
plus pauvres mais même au sein des pays
riches vous avez eu ce genre de problème
pour la nutrition des enfants parce
qu'il ya plus d'accès à la cantine etc
et pour les filles la scolarisation des
filles
on voit très bien on mesurait déjà ce
risque est maintenant on le constate
qu'il ya un risque clé chine revienne
pas à l'école dans un grand nombre de
pays et on a mesuré à l'unesco à risque
dont 11 millions de filles ne pas
retourner à l'école notamment pour les
adolescentes ou là aussi c'est un âge
clé un âge sensibles ou la fermeture des
écoles fait que les jeunes filles
pouvaient aller pour les unes travail et
ramener d'argent pour d'autres ce sont
des grossesses précoces pour d'autres
des mariages d'enfants et ça ça veut
dire que ce sont des destin bouleversé
ce sont des filles qui ne retourneront
pas à l'école des filles qui ne pourront
pas maîtriser leur destin donc c'est
très grave
et là aussi c'est une régression
formidable
il est encore à venir voici parce que
voilà ce sont les charges d'une fiction
les femmes de demain exactement il n'y a
pas de facteur peut-être plus de
transformationnel des sociétés que
l'éducation des filles à l'éducation des
femmes aujourd'hui dans le monde
sur les 750 millions de personnes qui ne
savent ni lire ni écrire
les deux tiers sont des femmes et on a
encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir
sur la scolarisation des filles
cette crise voilà c'est un facteur
aggravant c'est pour ça que nous avons
lancée à l'unesco des campagnes pour le
retour des filles à l'école
c'est pour ça que nous avons aidé à
l'éducation en général à distance parce
que cette perte d apprentissage est
extrêmement pénalisante pour notre
avenir à tous et oui il est vrai que le
coc vide a eu un énorme impact sur
l'éducation en général pour les filles
et les garçons on voit que les pays ont
très diversement impacter la pandémie
sur la fermeture de leur école on va
voir un graphique d'ailleurs de l'unesco
qui m'ont très bien
voilà les différences entre les pays on
voit par exemple qu'il y a eu plus de
quarante et une semaine fermé aux états
unis dans une bonne partie de l'amérique
latine
autour d'une dizaine de semaines en
france donc c'est vraiment l' inverse à
ce que vous estimez que la fermeture des
écoles a été tout de même une bonne
décision la moins mauvaise compte tenu
de la situation sanitaire où on en
aurait jamais dû en arriver là mais en
tout cas nous on a poussé pour la le
maintien d'une éducation alors il ya des
situations où il y avait beaucoup
d'incertitude rappelez-vous au début de
la pandémie pas assez d'études on savait
pas très bien si les enfants étaient en
danger ou pas donc les écoles à ce
moment là on comprend qu'elle ait été
fermé mais ce qu'il fallait je le suis
toujours pas trop bien derrière il ya
quand même de plus en plus il ya quand
même des études de plus en plus après il
ya les mutations du virus qui font que
de toute façon c'est un sujet
extrêmement mouvant mais donc ce qu'il
fallait à ce moment là c'est de
l'éducation à distance garder un lien et
c'était très compliqué pour tous les
pays et beaucoup de pays où il n'ya pas
d'accès en afrique neuf enfants sont dix
n'ont pas accès à un ordinateur
il ya la moitié de la population qui n'a
pas accès internet et puis on a vu que
même quand on a accès internet c'est
très compliqué les profs sont pas
forcément formés à ça les familles
peuvent pas forcément gérer ce temps là
donc on a voulu après l unesco nous
avons poussé nous avons même fait des
guides avec le ms avec l'unicef et c'est
pour réouvrir dès que possible les
écoles dans la sécurité
et c'est d'ailleurs aussi pour ça que
nous avons appelé en décembre quand il
est le premier vaccin parce que les
enseignants fassent partie des publics
prioritaires à vacciner pour que lorsque
les écoles ouvrent elles puissent
demeurer ouvertes ou pour qu'ils soient
elles puissent être s'immobiliser dans
l'éducation à distance
oui ils vont d'ailleurs bientôt être
vraiment prioritaire pour être vaccinées
en france du coup pour vous c'était une
bonne solution finalement de garder les
écoles ouvertes en france un maximum
ah c'est sûr que voudrait que c'est
possible y'a rien qui remplace l'école
on voit toutes les limites de
l'enseignement à distance
il ya des choses il ya eu des
innovations formidable nous par exemple
on a formé beaucoup de profs dans dans
les pays
du sud à faire des cours à la télévision
à la radio
y'a pas il n'ya pas uniquement les cours
en ligne donc il ya eu beaucoup
d'innovations beaucoup de choses mais on
voit bien que rien ne remplace
l'émulation du groupe
le regard du professeur cette attention
ceci tout ce qui se joue dans une classe
ne peut pas se jouer à distance et puis
à tous les sujets de décrochage dont on
parlait notamment pour les filles donc
dès que les écoles peuvent être ouvertes
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut savoir pas autorisés est ce que
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui cette
pandémie est en train d'occasionner un
sacrifice générationnel celui des
enfants des étudiants des jeunes dans
leur ensemble aujourd'hui c'est le
risque parce que encore une fois il ya
des âges clés l'éducation ces filles qui
reviendront pas à l'école elles
reviendront pas plus tard donc c'est là
que se joue il faut toujours avoir ça en
tête et puis il faut toujours garder cet
intérêt en tête
on sait bien mesurer l'impact de
fermeture des commerces sur la
croissance économique
on sait mesurer tout ça est ce qu on
sait mesurer tous les impacts à long
terme de la fermeture des écoles
on a essayé de faire d'ailleurs nous
avec avec la banque mondiale mais mais
ça fait partie
de notre intérêt commun à tous à long
terme et vous savez que les effets à
long terme s'est jamais là on est les
meilleurs pour les pour les anticiper
pour les alors les mesures et
justement si on parle un peu
d'anticipation ont bien deux c'est de
guérir cette situation comment rattraper
les apprentissages qui ont été perdus et
comment aussi préparé l'école à pouvoir
faire face à ce type de situation demain
il faut aussi arriver à tirer les leçons
de cette crise c'est un grand défi
d'abord sur les apprentissages nous
avons deux premières projections qui
sont vraiment très sérieuse parce qu'il
montre qu'on a on aura probablement là à
la fin de cette année scolaire 100
millions enfants de plus qui ne maîtrise
pas les compétences minimales en lecture
c'est à dire que ça augmente de 20%
là où dans une situation non pandémique
ça aurait baissé de 2% donc il ya des
impacts sur les apprentissages ça veut
dire que du point de vue pédagogique
quand les enfants reprennent les cours
l'école on ne peut pas faire comme si de
rien n'était et ça c'est quelque chose
que qu'on travaille avec tous les
ministères de l'éducation pour rattraper
ce retard pour faire des choses
particulières ya aussi tout un impact
psycho social très fort on l'a on
commence à le voir maintenant ils
étaient tous les pédopsychiatres le
disais alemagna croit d'ailleurs annoncé
des séances gratuites chez les
psychologues pour les séparer tout dans
les temps c'est une bonne
c'est partout dans le monde on voit
qu'il ya eu aussi cet impact de santé de
santé mentale et on voit encore une fois
ce qu'apporte l'école alors la pandémie
a ôté aussi synonyme d'un grand black
out sur le monde de la culture
les salles de cinéma fermé les musées
fermés les salles de spectacles fermé
avec tout de même un certain nombre de
nuances 1 selon les pays
on va regarder notamment au niveau des
pays européens
la plupart des salles de cinéma des pays
européens sont restés fermés l'espagne a
ouvert ses salles de spectacle avec
protocoles sanitaires strictes
il ya eu tout de même des concerts aux
tests qui ont été organisées en
allemagne à barcelone encore et puis il
y a eu des musées ouverts en suisse en
allemagne à madrid et puis très
récemment au portugal
est ce que vous vous comprenez les choix
par exemple qui ont été faits en france
et les choix l'on était très strictes si
on les compare à nos voisins avec
fermeture de toutes les salles et de
tous les musées il y avait des cheveux
très différents à travers le monde
on l'a vu on regarde par exemple nous
tous les sites du patrimoine mondiaux
vous savez ces fameux site classé à
l'unesco
là pour le coup 90% étaient fermés après
la question a été différente sur les
salles les salles de spectacle et musées
même si dans la très grande majorité ils
étaient plutôt plutôt fermé là aussi je
crois qu'il faut être très pragmatique
au début on ne connaissait pas bien on
mesurait pas bien les effets de
circulation du virus
il faut des études il faut des cas
pratiques il faut regarder dans quelles
conditions on peut accueillir mais plus
la crise dure plus on s'aperçoit là
aussi de cet impact et matériel du
manque de culture on s'assèche le public
ça sèche et la culture ce n'est pas du
divertissement seulement oui c'est aussi
une façon d'apprendre c'est une façon
d'être ému c'est une façon de partager
des choses ensemble
donc si on est appelé à vivre longtemps
dans cette situation il faut trouver des
solutions adaptées qui arrive à
concilier les deux mais on peut pas
considérer que c'est un black out
complet qui peut rester dans la
rés quelle est aujourd'hui la situation
des musées au niveau mondial 15 mois
après le début de la pandémie
vous en avez pas aller à 30% ont dû
réduire leurs effectifs 6% ont dû fermer
et aujourd'hui comment comment se
dessine leur avenir alors on vient de
publier la justement une enquête
mondiale sur les musées pour mesurer la
baisse de la fréquentation
elle a été de 70 % la baisse des revenus
et là on voit très bien la différence
des modèles vous avez des musées privés
reposant uniquement sur la billetterie
le mécénat dont certains vendent leurs
collections aujourd'hui poursuivre
quelque chose qui n'est pas possible en
france
compte tenu de la législation et puis
vous avez des modèles public financement
public
et voilà ils sont soutenus c'est le cas
en france heureusement ils sont soutenus
dans cette crise puis ce sont aussi ils
ont innové et trouver des formats
digitaux parfois des nouveaux des
nouveaux publics
mais la situation est extrêmement grave
et là aussi on retrouve ce que c'est que
le musée le musée c'est un rôle citoyen
c'est l'éducation
là aussi les enfants qui n'ont pas été
au musée qui n'ont pas fait le lien
entre l'histoire de l'art ce qu'ils
apprennent en cours tout ça c'est ce
sont des pertes de chance ce sont des
pertes de connaissance sont des pertes
on ne fait pas le lien entre les choses
quand on n'a plus les musées dont il
faut vraiment les protéger les préserver
et nous nous avons appelé à un
financement public a cru parce que là on
retrouve quand même le rôle du
financement public pour amortir ces
crises et oui vous avez un peu dissipée
sur ce que je voulais vous montrer parce
que effectivement moi y avait vraiment
un exemple qui m'avait beaucoup marqué à
la fin de l'année 2020 c'est lorsque
l'opéra de londres a dû vendre à un
tableau de dali top dès fin 2020 pour
renflouer ses comptes ça la moindre
effectivement les différences de modèles
en france certes la dila
la situation du monde culturel des
intermittents du spectacle et c est très
compliqué mais ça nous rappelle tout de
même que on a un soutien soutien public
qui reste important et qu'il faut
préserver
oui et puis vous avez fait allusion aux
intermittents du spectacle les
internautes intéressés à ces un régime
social qui est justement fait pour gérer
ces flux d'activité cpie le fait qu'à
une précarité par nature dans le travail
des artistes des techniciens du
spectacle et c'est le point c'est une d
une des deux leçons majeures que nous
avons retenu deux d'un vaste ensemble de
débat que nous avons faits sur la
culture un mouvement nous avons appelé
really art à travers le monde plus de
100 débat dans de nombreux dans de
nombreux pays sus avec la société civile
les artistes le monde de la création
parfois les institutions et on en a fait
la synthèse l'un des deux points c'était
qu'il faut absolument améliorer le
statut social des professionnels de la
culture et notamment des artistes et des
techniciens du spectacle
en france il ya un régime qui existe et
qu'il faut conserver et protéger mais il
ya aussi tous tout ce qui s'est passé
avec l'accélération du numérique le
numérique n'a pas été ancrée c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire tendance pendant
cette période et les acteurs les grands
acteurs les grandes plateformes
digitales les grandes plateformes de
vidéos de vidéos en ligne ont pris une
place accrue et le financement de la
culture par les acteurs du numérique qui
est une question qui se pose déjà depuis
longtemps elle devient absolument
essentiel les mots justes sur un petit
peu ce débat où la france a été montré
par certains autres pays où par exemple
l'allemagne avait parlé de la france
comme de l'absurde distant au moment où
elle avait eu des règles sur les
commerces essentielles non essentiels et
c est notamment il y avait eu tout ce
débat autour des livres qui ont été
considérées pendant deuxième confinement
comme non essentiels vous vous le
déplorez alors un moment il a présenté
dit
du bon côté voilà songe aux dires de la
liste comme ça et je crois qu'en tout
cas ce qui est évident c'est que c'est
une période de grandes interrogations
aussi il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
remises en cause on a besoin de sens
c'est le moment on a le besoin de plus
de culture en réalité on a besoin de
sens on a besoin de réflexion et les
livres restent à la fois ce refuge cette
consolation mais aussi cette mise en
perspective et cette réflexion et nous
avons besoin de nous sommes des foules
sentimentales pour reprendre les mots
d'alain flausch en a besoin elles et
pour terminer nous allons parler bien de
la question de la liberté de la presse
la liberté de la presse pas en chine pas
à l'étranger mais en france dans ce pays
où la liberté de la presse semble pas
être un acquis il y a eu et bien ce cas
ce cas de morgan large cette journaliste
qui enquête sur l'industrie
agroalimentaire en bretagne qui a été
victime d'une tentative de sabotage
mettant en danger sa vie et celle de sa
famille ce cas montre l'enquêté en
france aujourd'hui peut-être encore
dangereux risqué écoutez bien le
témoignage d'inès l'hérault journaliste
elle aussi elle a fait l'objet de
tentatives d'intimidation après ces
enquêtes sur les algues vertes
là encore en bretagne les représentants
de l'agroalimentaire sont très bien
infiltré dans la société bretonne
ils ont un certain pouvoir déjà sur la
presse régionale puisqu'il la finance
via les encarts publicitaires
ils sont aussi au sein même du conseil
régional et la région bretagne est une
région qui subventionne le plus les
industries et notamment agroalimentaires
dans sa région mais ça s'observe aussi à
l'échelon national parce que qui préside
qui sont présidents et vice-présidents
de l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui ce
sont de fervents défenseurs du système
agroalimentaire breton est à la tête de
grands médias comme comme canal+ il ya
aussi des personnalités très proches du
lobby agroalimentaire breton les
enquêtes ont été très difficiles à
placer dans les médias nationaux et dans
les médias rage et régionaux il ya un
certain silence sur les violences et les
menaces et les pressions exercées par là
le système agroalimentaire breton voilà
encore un témoignage édifiant la liberté
de la presse n'est donc pas un acquis
par tous pas dans toutes les démocraties
qui pourtant les riches en principe
fondamental est ce que
vous surprend cette affaire c'est un
combat permanent la liberté de la presse
est partout et notamment pour le
journalisme d'investigation il ya eu ce
le meurtre de sept journalistes à malte
d'arrivée daphné caruana gallizia qui
nous l'a qui nous l'a rappelé une
tendance très préoccupante quand on
regarde les meurtres de journalistes
journalistes assassinés parce qu'ils
font leur métier
avant c'était majoritairement sur des
zones de conflits dans les zones de
guerre
et bien maintenant ce sont
majoritairement hors des zones de
conflit est souvent ces journalistes
d'investigation c'est très préoccupant
oui c'est très préoccupant et puis on
voit aussi que ça peut être une cause
qui est difficile à défendre d'une part
vous avez les pays où la presse est
libre elle n'existe pas et puis il ya
des pays comme le nôtre où en plus la
presse est quand même extrêmement
critique et fait l'objet d'une défiance
de la part de la population et donc ce
n'est pas du tout évident dans ce
contexte il ya toute une confiance a
regagné entre les médias les médias les
citoyens il ya aussi tout un sujet
d'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
parce que malheureusement on voit aussi
que les libertés nouvelles qui vont avec
avec le numérique avec les réseaux
sociaux c'est aussi beaucoup de
désinformation c'est parfois des
campagnes d'ailleurs d'intimidation en
ligne contre des journalistes notamment
les femmes journalistes
donc il ya aussi tout un travail
d'éducation aux médias et à
l'information qu'il faut mener de façon
plus moderne en prenant en compte
justement la diffusion de l'information
sur les mails réseaux sociaux et bien
merci merci beaucoup
désolé d'avoir été l'invitée du grand
entretien dalons plus loin